apple's iphone 14 design is finally
finalized and we're starting to get a
bunch of new leaks and rumors pointing
to the features that we should be
expecting throughout the lineup which by
the way is now missing the iphone mini
yes you heard that correctly multiple
accurate sources like ross young are now
100 certain that the mini will be gone
from the iphone 14 lineup but don't
worry a totally new iphone model will be
replacing it and it's actually a genius
plan but before i get into that i want
to go through some terrible news for the
iphone 14 that we literally just got the
other day and i'm afraid that there will
be a lot of upset customers if this
actually does happen according to
minchiko who now finally has a twitter
account which has been verified by both
mac rumors and 9.5 mac
only the two iphone 14 pro and pro max
models will actually be getting the new
a16 bionic chip this year now this is
likely going to be a huge disappointment
to a lot of people and this is such a
big deal that people on twitter are
starting to question ming's credibility
because this seems so odd but the big
question that remains is why in the
world would apple do this and how do
they think that they can actually get
away with it well the major point i want
to make is that for the first time ever
the current iphone 13 lineup features a
clear performance difference between the
regular models and the pro models with
two different versions of the a15 chip
one with a 4 core gpu for the regulars
and one with a 5 core for the pro models
this basically shows us that apple is
willing to use performance as a
differentiating feature between the low
and high end models so this year they
could take it even further but the even
bigger problem is that it seems like for
the first time ever there won't be any
performance upgrade going from an iphone
13 to a 14 but that's actually not true
i personally believe that if apple does
stick to the a15 chip on the regular 14
models they're gonna give it the faster
five core version which is currently
exclusive to the pro models and this
would actually make the 14 an upgrade
compared to the 13 in terms of graphics
performance and this actually makes a
lot of sense because the brand new
iphone se now comes with the 4 core
version of the a15 so the regular 14 is
gonna get the five core version and then
with that said it seems like apple gave
the ipad air 5 the m1 chip instead of
the a15 just to help the supply of a15
chips in the future iphone 14 models but
another huge point i want to make is
that the a15 chip is actually more than
enough for the regular iphone 14s and
here is why first of all not everyone
upgrades every single year so people
with older iphones won't really care
that much that it's the same a15 chip
from the iphone 13 lineup since it's
actually still crazy fast and it's still
going to be the more powerful 5 core gpu
version and on top of that android
smartphone chips are still way behind
what apple has to offer for example
there was a ton of hype over qualcomm's
new snapdragon 8 gen 1 chip but it
turned out to be a massive
disappointment in terms of the
performance and battery life usage we
even did a gaming test comparing the
ipad pro to samsung's brand new galaxy
tab s8 ultra which features this new
chip and it was a huge disappointment
not even being able to sustain a solid
60 fps and gentian impact within that
massive 14.6 inch chassis while the ipad
pro averaged higher than 100 fps and
then making things worse geekbench
revealed that samsung's gos or game
optimizing service was unfairly
targeting benchmark apps and only giving
the chips full performance in those apps
while drastically slowing down the
chip's performance in real world apps
like games to help keep the temperatures
down and some people even leaked the
actual performance with gos on during
benchmarks and these chips get much
slower showing how they actually
compared to apple's chips while in real
workflows so because of this apple's a15
ship is untouchable for another year at
least and now before i jump into some
actually good news and brand new leaks
concerning apple's iphone 14 lineup i
want to make my final point about why
only the pro models will be getting the
a16 chip this year first of all apple
seems to be wanting to sell more pro
models and this makes sense because
that'll help them bring their average
sales price up which is very important
to their investors and the second reason
is that all of the main sources
including ming chi quo and ross young
fully believe that the new iphone lineup
will now introduce a brand new iphone 14
max model which will pack essentially
the same base feature set as the regular
14 but now with a larger 6.7 inch
display and in my opinion the regular 14
will start at 799 with a 100 price jump
up to the larger 14 max and then you'll
have to pay an extra 300
for the pro and pro max models for each
corresponding size and yes that means
that the pro models will now be a
hundred dollars more expensive compared
to last year and i'll explain why in
just a minute but the main point i want
to make is that now that apple for the
first time ever has two models with a
larger 6.7 inch display they need to
make it very clear and have clear
distinctions and differences between the
regular 14 max model and the more
expensive 14 pro max so that users can
easily tell the difference for example
we're already 100 certain that only the
pro models will be coming with the new
dual punch hole cutout on the display
while the regular 14 models including
the brand new 14 max will still have a
notch and to make things worse we've
been getting reports that the lower end
14 models will have the same display
bezels as the current 13 while the 14
pro models will get thinner bezels which
look much nicer and just yesterday
imagine boo released these new images of
the dual cutout display and it honestly
looks really really nice in my opinion
and this user even lined up the cutouts
with the current notch design and it's
clear that apple has a real winner with
these new 14 pro models but on top of
that apple is planning to have even more
differences like ross young confirming
that 120 hertz promotion will once again
be exclusive to the pro models so the
regular 14s will still be sticking to a
60 hertz display and now the last point
i want to make for why apple is only
giving the new a16 chip to the pro
models is that apple's costs for this
chip will be quite a bit higher than the
a15 first of all tsmc has already
announced that they're raising prices
for their best and latest process nodes
bringing costs up going further micciko
believes that the new a16 ships will use
faster and more expensive lp ddr5 ram
and there are rumors that the a16 will
be the first chip to use tsmc's new
expensive 3d fabric technology but the
real big problem in my opinion is that
there have been some real supply chain
issues that are putting pressure on
apple's profit margins so it makes sense
to put cheaper chips on the lower end
models while forcing users to pay more
for these brand new expensive chips and
making things even worse shenzhen china
which houses the biggest apple product
factory in the world has just gone into
full lockdown which will add to these
supply problems so with that said maybe
apple just can't afford to take the
profit margin hit by giving the lower
end iphones the latest chip especially
since inflationary and commodity price
pressures have gotten even worse over
the past couple of months but now with
the bad news out of the way let's
finally get into the good news all
iphone 14 models are expected to get a
full redesign with protruding flat glass
on both the front and the back as well
as the possibility of getting a usb-c
port but that's still uncertain and the
iphone 14 pro models are gonna be
incredible this year with that new
beautiful dual punch design as well as
the titanium chassis the new 48
megapixel main camera on the back for
shooting 8k video and of course the new
a16 chip but as for the iphone 14 it
could have even better battery life
thanks to a new more efficient 5g chip
and there are some rumors that apple
will finally be selling a new smaller 30
watt power adapter using gan technology
which of course you'll have to buy
separately and to be honest that's about
it for the good news so hopefully you
enjoyed this video and if you did go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out one of those
two right over there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you